everyone's favorite dog loving killing
machine is back for his highly
anticipated threequel and now we've been
left to piece together the puzzle of
another pulse-pounding final act here's
the ending of John wick chapter 3 para
bellum
explained para bellum follows the
satisfying formula of the previous wick
flicks
so the amped up events of act 3 don't
come as a total surprise in Morocco the
elder the bigwig in the high table a
super serious worldwide Council of crime
lords kicks off the film's final act by
giving wick a choice he can kill
continental NYC manager and wick Ally
Winston and live his remaining days as a
high table hitman or he can die in the
Sahara after a gruesome act of
solidarity slicing off his ring finger
and giving his wedding band to the elder
wick heads to the Continental where a
surprising switcheroo awaits him
courtesy of the high table every wick
fan knows that there are two rules in
the wick firs that carry serious
consequences if they're broken not
honoring a marker which is a blood bound
oath and most importantly conducting
assassination business on any
Continental property around the globe in
Chapter three closing act a mysterious
figure known as the adjudicator voids
the ladder law declaring the NYC
Continental as deconsecrated in order to
send heavily-armored high table thugs
into the hotel these super soldiers are
tasked with taking down John wick since
wick chose not to take down Winston
despite the whole cutting off his own
ring finger thing this armored assault
doesn't work of course and after much
fancy choreographed grappling which
defeats the high table goons and the
adjudicators hired assassin zero and his
blade happy crew after the dust settles
the adjudicator agrees to let Winston
stay in the safety of the hotel but
let's wants to know that wick is still
very much a thorn in the high tables
side what Winston does next is a bit
ambiguous but it sure looks like
betrayal at first glance in the swanky
rooftop garden of the Continental
scene in Chapter two Winston suddenly
shoots wicks several times causing him
to fall to the alley below did Winston
really intend to kill wick it's left
unclear but there's certainly an
argument to be made that Winston would
have just shot wick in the head if he
truly wanted him dead instead of
shooting him in the bulletproof suit he
received from the elder plus there's the
tick-tock man all too conveniently
waiting nearby to help escort wicks body
away not to mention the exchange between
continental concierge sharone and
Winston where sharone assures his boss
that everything's in place
Winston's plan it appears was to fake
wicks death with the help of the Bowery
King and then use wick to try and take
down the high table with this in mind
and wicks fall being somewhat slowed by
awnings outside the Continental a
building Winston knows better than
anyone which survival at the end can't
just be a case of good fortune further
evidence of this risky plan comes early
when wick strategically shoots an
underworld doctor in such a manner that
it appears as if he was trying to kill
him but he's left alive if wick knows
how to convincingly fake kill somebody
Winston probably does as well bottom
line if Winston wants to take down the
high table he knows the only man capable
of it is wick the unstoppable boogeyman
every trained killer knows and respects
the real question is whether or not wick
who genuinely seemed surprised when he
was shot by Winston was in on it did wit
fake his reaction did wick and Winston
work this all out off screen during say
the deconsecrated montage featuring the
madmen meets suicide girls receptionists
we don't know for sure but it's a safe
bet that Winston chose to save wicks
life by faking his death at least
temporarily with no evidence of his
demise wicks in the same place he was at
the end of chapter two excommunicated
and wanted by every killer for hire in
the wick furs but this time wick appears
to be done running and is likely eager
to turn the tide against the
all-powerful High table as Chiron puts
it to Winston after wicks rooftop tumble
well-played sir after Winston's supposed
betrayal wicks fate is unknown to the
high table until the adjudicator sees
that the super assassins body has gone
missing in a twist that everybody and
their pitbulls saw coming it turns out
that Wikus alive
having found a refuge in the Bowery
Kings new hideout
the Bowery King sliced seven times by
zero' a call back to when he hooked wick
up with seven bullets back in chapter 2
tells wick he's pissed off wick agrees
with that sentiment setting up what's
sure to be another beautifully
choreographed and absurdly violent
installment in John wick chapter 4
nothing's official regarding John wick
for yet but director Chad's two house
key told Entertainment Weekly in 2018
that the wick well hasn't run dry if
people go see the movie and it makes
money and they come back to us Keanu and
I have ideas for days interestingly
enough Stachowski later told indieWIRE
that despite all appearances the end of
John wick 3 wasn't necessarily intended
as a cliffhanger the trusty wick formula
according to stay house key demands that
when the end credits roll wick is either
left alive and hunted by the deadliest
people on the planet or he's dead as a
doornail the director told indieWIRE do
you think he's going to ride off into
the sunset
he's killed 300 people and he's just
going to walk away everything's ok if
you're this guy if this guy really
existed how is this guy's day going to
end he's for the rest of his life it's
just a matter of time the somewhat
ambiguous ending to chapter 3 will
likely get cleared up in act 1 of John
wick 4 but until then our artisanal gold
coins are on Winston waging a skirmish
with wicks help on the seemingly
invincible high table check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bells so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]